hey everyone I'm Ilana and welcome to my
channel where today I am unboxing a
Google stadia this is the founders
edition it's a nice box and I do have to
disclose this video is sponsored by
Google they did send me this stadia very
cool thing it says my name on the box
I love that but any of you have been
following me for a while will probably
already know that I care a lot about the
direction the video game industry is
headed in and about the tech that drives
that and I feel like stadia and what it
does is the beginning of a new wave of
extremely accessible video games so for
anyone who isn't familiar with this
whole thing the whole point is that it
lets you play games across multiple
platforms like you can swap from a
laptop to your TV to your desktop even
some tablets and smartphones you can use
pretty much anywhere that has Wi-Fi
which obviously right now is a lot of
places and you can do all of that
without actually needing a console you
don't need your Xbox one or ps4 you just
need this software really you also don't
have to wait for games to download I
tweeted recently that I think it sucks
that we've somehow moved into an era
where you have to wait for games to
download rather than having moved out of
it like when I was growing up playing
video games we didn't have wait times
how do we get back there stadia games
streaming services in general intend to
completely get rid of that it just
streams the games directly onto which
ivo device you want to play on so yes
this is very exciting tech you know so
send me this little card here welcome to
studio we're excited for you to be among
the first place stadia and all new
gaming platform from google list ad you
can play high quality video games across
your favorite device is deployed in TVs
laptops tests all that stuff folks and
tablets they also emailed me my city I
found his addition code and it says that
along with what's in this box is all you
need to start playing
we can't wait to begin this new
generation of gaming with you yeah so
just checking yes I did get the code I
did also get three months of the stadia
pro subscription which give what
gives you access to premium specs which
is like 4k with HDR 5.1 surround sound
on TV the growing library of games
beginning with destiny to the collection
and exclusive discounts you also get a
buddy pass or I'm about to get a buddy
pass which lets you give a stadia access
code and three months stadia Pro
subscription to a friend but let's open
the box shall we okay here we have a V
controller it's because it's weird that
this is technically a video game
platform and this is all that's in the
box so this is the limited edition night
blue stadia controller it's really light
that's my first impression it feels
comfortable I feel like I'll need to put
a ton of time into it to tell you how I
really feel about first impression light
it's pretty sleek not too busy yeah
we'll have to check it out okay what
else do we got a USBC cable oh my light
went out great did you really make a
youtube video if you didn't have a
thousand problems doing it so yeah USBC
cable standard stuff and then this is
the Google chromecast Ultra I'm gonna be
honest I've never seen one of these
before it is a lot smaller than I
expected this is basically all you need
to play games via the stadia platform on
your TV so that's pretty nuts and then
obviously that also comes with a power
cable which also has an ethnic port in
the back there I was thinking that I'd
maybe have to like move some stuff
around but no what good this thing's
gonna fit anyway but I will say if you
missed out on the founders edition
because these are completely sold out I
am really stoked to have gotten my hands
on this you can still get the stadia
premier edition that includes a clearly
white standee controller and chromecast
ultra as well as three months of stadia
pro the premium subscription and I will
leave a link in the description below to
where you can grab one of those if you
want to get your hands on one so this is
everything in the box it's nothing it's
so weird let's set it up shall we
okay so because I can't move too far
away from my PC to use my microphone
we're gonna use the camera audio for a
bit which sorry if that's not as good
but basically what I've done now is
download the stadia app which is
required I put in my code and I guess
they just have to sign up but then I
also plugged the chromecast
into the TV I don't even know how to
show you that setup because it's just
plugging that little black disc into an
HDMI port very simple okay
I'm logged in it says onwards so let's
hit that okay I'm officially in stadium
okay my TV is giving me a code I'm not
gonna get too elaborate into how to set
up a chromecast because I know a lot of
people already have these but it's
really a couple minutes seems pretty
easy I haven't had one okay TV now says
setup you're saying control using the
stadium mobile app at the end of setup
you'll be asked to enter this linking
code so I'm gonna go press the little
controller icon it's honestly like
strange to have to use an app to set up
a console but very cool how quick this
is like there's just a little interface
for controllers and I just have to click
on my controller to connect it so okay I
think we're unlocked control linked from
now and turning on your stadia control
over launch data on this TV this could
take up to 30 seconds you may need to
link it again right on the screens okay
cool
so I basically can select a game I'm
gonna go with destiny 2 and it should
pretty much just I press claim it should
just throw the game to my TV I'm pretty
sure that's nuts
I just pressed claim and now tell my TV
okay let me show you this okay
Mike's gonna sound slightly different
again because we've moved also if you
see flickering on my TV it's because of
my lens not because of the stadia itself
but basically here's what we have on my
phone you all we have to do is just boom
okay I'm here for it okay we go one
final location change so that I can
avoid having you guys stare at my ugly
reflective TV I'm instead going to try
playing the game on Chrome this should
be as easy as me literally typing stadia
calm into the browser I have to be
loaded into my Google account it's
obviously linked to my app and then I'm
pretty sure the game will just be there
that's okay let's give it a shot okay
there it is press play it's full screen
you
that this is nuts
connecting signing in you know I'm
probably gonna make a new account really
quick right now so that I don't have to
pay with Bungie let's go let's go let's
go with the Titan female Titan I like
that one always liked that one the most
I mean this is running perfectly there
is absolutely no lack nothing yeah this
is this is very impressive I definitely
want to see what gameplay looks like but
right now this is insane it looks
perfect to me
okay gameplay I'm playing on a laptop
right now for the record this place is
an old cosmodrome uh spaceport I there
is from what I can tell absolutely no
lag the game looks really good
I I have no complaints I can't tell the
difference this sure is destiny to again
it's running perfectly it looks we need
a ship exactly as it should I be
interested see a comparison video but I
mean I can't I can't
floor this I am very impressed
[Music]
I brought you back let's see how combat
works that made us like otherwise I am
just extremely impressed we're deep in
enemy territory a little bit of a hiccup
there but could also be the Internet
where are you at bud
this is
I should also mention it playing on a
trackpad which is the worst way to play
this yeah so this is insane you kind of
get the idea I think this is me
literally babones literally with the
trackpad just jumping to a laptop typing
in say datacom and then destiny is here
this is the least effort you can even
put into something and it runs and it
looks fantastic I mean I think this is
incredible I know people have had
different experiences with launch but
mine has been very positive of course
thank you to stadia for providing me
with a stadia if you want to get one to
found a position that I showed in this
video is sold out but there's a link
below to where you can actually get your
hands on one and yeah thank you everyone
for watching this video I hope it was
informative a good first look at what
this tech that might be the future of
our industry actually looks like right
now
alright I'm Alana and I will see you
guys next time